in a new interview that she just gave
Oprah said that she asked God if she
should run for president and so far she
hasn't heard back yeah when reached for
comment God said he's still working up
the courage to speak to Oprah big story
White House communications director hope
Hicks is stepping down she is stepping
down that was just announced a couple
hours ago yeah what is this hee-haw
what's going on in here making barnyard
sounds true story White House
communications director hope Hicks
reportedly admitted to investigators
that she told some white lies on behalf
of President Trump yeah yeah then Hicks
admitted that that was a white lie and
in fact she actually makes up [ __ ] all
the time
Pacific story Jared Kushner as of Friday
as of last Friday Jared Kushner no
longer has top security clearance top
secret security clearance yeah so now if
Kushner wants access to classified
information he'll have to read present
Trump's tweets like everybody else
[Applause]
I've added a hamburger to my axe yeah
yeah makes a makes me nervous he's gonna
bite into the black burger yeah any time
now yesterday this is a weird story but
follow me on this yesterday China banned
the letter n from its internet yeah they
banned the letter n from their internet
yeah
whereas China is now called Chia to get
by with that now that's a weird one how
do you even understand that one that's
true story
I'm not kidding it still hurt see you
later
I mean hurts in a good way Papa John's
in the news Papa John's announced they
will no longer be a sponsor for the NFL
yeah after hearing this peyton manning
said wait you mean i've been eating this
crap for nothing that's not a pizza
there's no way that's the pizza who here
enjoys anyone here enjoy a Papa John's
Pizza huh
no seriously not because you can hear
yourself in a bar later tonight
applauding because you really do enjoy a
pop you do no he doesn't oh it's a
yarmulke that fell on some cheese all
right if it's cheese in Arizona do they
buy advertising on the show oh they do
what are you doing talk to me before the
show and tell me who buys advertising
find product that Papa John's sir you
and I are going out there as soon as the
show is over Papa John's
hey in Arizona after a couple found out
that a house they just bought had been
used to shoot pornos they withdrew their
offer yeah well technically they pulled
out
[Applause]
[Music]
and with that joke he left show business
forever
you